buongiorno ragazzi benvenuti a una nuova
puntata del blog massa oggi mi è venuto
in mente un'idea per passare la giornata
ho chiesto a gianmarco enrico di venire
a casa mia con della strumentazione loro
non sanno esattamente cosa voglio fare
la mia idea è quella di aggiungere un
tassello molto importante a quelle che
sono le fiabe legate alla pa le basta
canto di natale basta tutta quella roba
lì è bastato schiaccianoci è arrivato
forse il momento di aggiungere qualcosa
e più moderno che potremmo veramente
raccontare i nostri figli in futuro e
che potrà far parte del grandissimo
parterre di autori di storie legate a
una particolare festività dell'anno
prego e lui non sa se posso dirvi spero
che anche i miei parenti e prendono con
altrettanto entusiasmo belle
inquadrature questa qui è una
grandissima sorpresa
spetta a parte qualcuno conosciuto in
giro della sicilia se non mi ricordavo
in quale video fosse comparso proprio
quello al solo solo quello che sto
facendo con la differenziata curdo la
differenziata ma cosa ha fatto la
differenziata urbana differenziata
illuminato burtone frega niente
allora va bene tutto ma tu mi hai fatto
portare un quantitativo di roba gratis
le torce che quello stai facendo già un
ostaggio innocente perché mi ha fatto
portare morso è normato fine di ogni
tanto un super sayan filati tornerà
molto utile giocare ti prendi tutti i
giocatori più belli chiari qualcosa
la cosa fila di testa già dividendo
qualcosa meno male ha provato ad
aggredire la cosa che non gli può fare
nulla
concludo posso spiegare che cosa voglio
fare
potevi fare numero come al solito il
boss ragazzi
[Applauso]
allora prestando è una fiaba natalizia è
già un'idea assolutamente sì per veri
ciak del ciak azione dal papa
para papa sara pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa
pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa col potere
conferito miga silente vuoi tu jennifer
sposare mario sì lo voglio
e vuoi tu mario sposare jennifer sì lo
voglio
in tal caso vi dichiaro marito e moglie
del regista la scienza del bacio barbara
jennifer è una ragazza timida reazione
ridammi la battuta sì lo voglio più
angelico sì lo voglio
eccellente vada di passare in camerino
grazie regista come posso fare essere
una brava attrice e regista mi ha detto
di farlo in un certo modo io la farò in
quel modo
sì il buio non si è l'uomo li stanno
facendo le prove si stavo provando sai
ho ancora qualche problema con cui la
scena comunque barbara da quando abbiamo
cominciato a lavorare insieme come
miscelato a provare qualcosa perché devo
dirti una cosa vai primato se come un
fratello per me il mio ragazzo memore di
che cosa succede ai barbaro a dire una
cosa devi pure che succede passano nove
non possono non tiene e che senso che
forse non lo so in un posto esotico ma
allora che cosa vuoi dirmi per caso da
xvi tania per prova e bonacossa lunga
ancora tocca se vuoi dal mio ragazzo
voglio dirti che tour a gazzano e più
tuo ragazzo è tuo e il ragazzo come ti
permette a terni una cosa simile ivona
andiamo superman
[Musica]
sotto
non chiedo di più sono io
un amore buio
l'amore non mi è mai piaciuto nelle arti
piange è arrivato il tuo b i suoi così
secco ha dimenticato di mettere la crema
stamattina papà è successa una cosa
terribile
si è lasciata superman red son oro è
normale soffrire per amore sì pure io
soffrì tanto e quando ci si per sbaglio
tua madre ricordo bene quel giorno
funesto deve essere stato terribile e lo
stato è comunque senti papa adesso vado
a cambiarmi che così non mi si può più
vedere aymara barbara mia figlia si sta
cambiando è nuda
quale pensa che sia il problema l'ho
visto da un milione di volte
come pensa che abbia avuto la partita
piacere regista cosa cosa io cosa tu
cosa è sotto ma sono pronta regista oggi
smetto di girare e ci vediamo domani eni
figliuola ti porto in un posto maggio
vini portati tra tesoro
prima però c'è una sorpresa per 3 2
[Musica]
non ci posso credere seminando l'amante
bracciale sorella aria e anche più
bianca sberla basta 5 pare ragazza è ora
di andare ladri ma domiciliato in questo
posto è un ragazzo a questo è il tempio
del magico entrato dove tutto può
iniziare buffi dire cenerentola che cosa
si fa solo la spagna mi subito che cosa
[Musica]
sono l'unica sopravvissuta bambino potrò
ancora sentirmi con la cosa ma sono
morte di punte tutte e tre le mie
migliori amiche della vita sono vecchio
non ci posso credere anche fortunati che
cosa giovino dopo la famiglia credo di
essermi fatto male quando cadeva
una mano ma un dolore che libertà un
incantesimo credo che succede abbiamo
pregato milan ma mi fai sulla madre che
cosa impara tutto normativo anzi il mago
cattivo che ho fatto
la maledizione del male tutti uguali
oddio sono soldi in un luogo che non
conosco un'ultima cosa si dica ti faccio
un regalino ora cammino un piccolo
presente qui divina che oramai a
tagliare ora marcia ciao mi chiamo per
nome fatto un piccolo presente qualche
carino non ho mai visto un essere così
piccolo e pieno di nardò a chimica più
che papà o che cosiddetto piccolo
accendeva più di moto male non ho capito
che è un maiale attendete di un puzzle
ieri che mi senti non capì scritto
linguaggio ma se un manigoldo battere
sono veramente sola forse ho un idea o
bene ho appena finito di costruire una
piccola cavalcatura con dei materiali di
scarto perché a tavoli cologia dove sarà
piccolo aiutami a tornare a casa che
sono io
lo sciamano che cosa vuoi fare
ora le dita di una mano e si fa pure non
siete per niente un eroinomani denutrito
non posso fare un incantesimo sud italia
600 per poveri vinta dai modelli
ma sono diventata una simile
luglio che cosiddetto rossi lo so anche
a te ma anche essendoci cavallo mio
piccolo amico squali forme ma non ti
preoccupare
troveremo un modo per tornare a casa
seguimi colpo c'è l'acqua ottimi chi è
quell'uomo mi chiamo azione tesori
guardiano di questo sentiero anche zio
nito genitori non dovevano volerti molto
baby che è un piccolo problema un
vecchio pelato ci ha fregato razze
voldemort spesso fa questi giochetti
adesso sono le sirene lui uno squalo ma
prima in un cavallo se volete passare di
qui dovrete risolvere un enigma che
installa insoluti che di gente
effettivamente non si diede lo sono più
da allora di mattina mi muovo a quattro
zampe di pomeriggio mi muovo a 2
la sera mi muovo è facilissimo lei
stesso anno esatto bravissimo cosimina
passare che fortune più caro nicola
mucci n'attimo finalmente abbiamo preso
dei nostri forme iniziali credo che sia
forse arrivato il momento di separarci
non pensi bene vai pure adesso dovrò
andare
oggi ho mangiato il nuovo peperoni che
sei temi pure maria teresa cui termini
non hanno fatto che serve
devo andare a casa nel motoria le molto
reale sì esattamente il mondo reale
grazie mille ok dovrà essere quasi
arrivata può giocare con noi no piccole
nale da smesso di essere una bambina
questo viaggio mi sta insegnando
diventare una donna ma del portone
arrivo aspetto quota ore spero che non
siano morte tutte papa e di abbracciare
e ringrazio anche sei ucciso predellini
migliori amiche ho capito che le foto
per il mio bene e per questo ti
ringrazio perché adesso ho finalmente
trovato me stessa
ti voglio bene papà frank io ti voglio
bene ora capisco che ucciso la mamma
finalmente sono tornata sul set
goal.com non sei stata l'arma a trovare
me stessa e ho capito tante cose di mac
os kg lane di danni voglio te come amico
con combattesse fattori messi io diretto
così quando mi arrabbio
non me ne sono mai resa conto ma io ti
amo anche io ti amo barba ragazzino ha
messo sbagliata ma come organo aiutiamo
barbara o che schifo barbara malabo
smettere cocus è cosa ho capito cosa ho
capito il senso del natale
qual è che bisogna essere superficiali
per campa bene
in tal caso vi dichiaro marito e moglie
devo dirti una cosa barbara in realtà
cocco anch'io devo un giorno si muove a
quattro zampe
a mezzogiorno forse devi dire il mattino
che sei molto bravo a testi di partire
di sera come la sera spero che non sia
una morte tutte bocconi norme mio by via
mosso a bra barbara
[Risate]
[Applauso]